make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and uh
make sure you guys hit the like button
if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin
what's going on guys this is rob and
with black adam coming out soon and that
movie featuring dr fate over the course
of the next however long this video ends
up being i'm going to make you an expert
on kent nelson but before we do
let's do a brand integration okay so we
have our disc plates set up here and i
actually kind of need to fix that one in
that one my ocd's driving me crazy uh
but we've got these things set up i need
to get a sixth one um i only got five
but these things look
and like we said in the last video these
things literally attach just using these
magnets to stick to uh sticky paper
right so you don't worry about tearing
up the wall when you attach these things
but there's something else that i want
to point out here so one thing to
remember is that these things are metal
right like these things are branded
metal designs so it's not like you're
gonna have problems with them in like 10
years these things are solid uh they
also have artists all over the world so
those of you guys who aren't just
interested in marvel comics but you're
also interested in like nature
landscapes different things like that
you can go to their website and you can
organize it based on genre or look up
things based on genre or you can look up
things based on just strict individual
brands so if all you want is star wars
you can find star wars so just like last
time the discount code is that you get
25 off for one or two plates or you can
get 29 off for three plates or more so
make sure you guys check the link in the
description make sure you guys go check
out this plate and let's get back into
the video
kent nelson also known as the first
doctor fate was created by gardner fox
and howard sherman and first appeared in
more fun comics number 55 in may of 1940
but we didn't really get any information
into the character's origin until about
a year later in more fun comics number
67 but in that story it's essentially
established that in 1920 kent nelson
went on an archaeological expedition
with his father to the valley of europe
where he discovered a temple containing
the tomb of naboo the wise who was an
ancient mesopotamian god now when ken
unwittingly awakens naboo a poisonous
gas is released and then ken's father is
essentially killed now naboo of course
feels bad for kim and so he takes him
under his wing and over the course of
the next two decades essentially teaches
him everything that naboo knows about
the mystic arts and then gives him an
amulet a helm and a cloak that imbue him
with vast magical abilities and so kent
basically then returns to america sets
up base in salem massachusetts and
operates as a superhero known as dr fate
now later in 1940 national allied
publications and all-american
publications the two companies that
would later merge to form dc comics
collaborated on the introduction of the
first team of superheroes in comic book
history known as the justice society of
america which debuted in all-star comics
number three now i do have a video that
does explain the justice society of
america you're welcome to check it out
after you're done watching this video
we'll have a link to it down in the
description but the thing about this is
that while these two companies would
eventually merge the truth is that the
jsa was actually their experiment to see
whether or not it was even worth
emerging in the first place and so the
way this played out is that dr fate was
one of the founding members of the team
alongside the specter our man and the
sandman who were on the national allied
publication side as well as the flash
green lantern hawkman and the atom from
the all-american publication side now
the justice society proved to be hugely
popular with fans and dr fate actually
continued to appear in their stories up
until issue number 21 of all star comics
in 1944 which was around the same time
that his solo series had basically been
cancelled as well now there's a reason
for this the reason simply being that
superheroes rose to prominence in the
1940s because of world war ii and so you
saw pretty much all the superheroes
batman superman wonder woman and dr fate
and the jsa were really no different
facing off against the axis powers the
problem with this is that by the time
world war ii ended people were just
tired of conflict and they considered
pretty much all superheroes to be
synonymous with world war ii so they
basically just stopped reading them now
some of the superheroes survived batman
superman wonder woman those mainstays
they survived because they were just
that popular but somebody like kent
nelson dr fate he wasn't really so
fortunate now one thing that i want to
establish is that it wasn't as though he
was wiped from existence from dc comics
that he actually appeared sparingly
throughout the next couple of decades
most notably in the annual crossovers
that took place between the justice
society and dc's other major superhero
team the justice league of america which
basically started happening in 1963 he
teamed up with superman a couple of
times in the world's finest comics and
he had like a one-issue solo story in
1975 but by and large he was just kept
on the shelf like dc just kind of
shelved him and just sort of walked away
now there was an attempt in 1980 with dc
special series number 10 to give him a
new origin but the only reason why that
happened is because prior to that dc had
actually given new origins to other
superheroes whose sales were basically
struggling superman was a good example
of that and so dc's assumption was if it
worked for a lot of these other
characters it might very well work for
doctor fate it didn't
it didn't really work for dr fate at all
and so in the mid 1980s and 1985 dc
wrote a story called crisis on infinite
earths now the basis behind this story
was because dc's multiverse which was
established in 1961 with the flash of
two world story it had just become
ridiculously unruly and convoluted and
it made it almost impossible for anybody
who had never read comics to get into
the dc comic landscape now the
significance behind crisis on infinite
earth is that it took the entirety of
the multiverse that dc had and it
condensed it down into a singular
universe the problem that you had to
answer here was that if by this point in
time it was established that dr fate and
the justice society of america existed
in an alternate reality called earth 2
and that the justice league of america
was in an alternate reality called earth
1 how in the world do you square that
circle how do you establish or how do
you continue on the stories of a team
that exists in a universe that doesn't
exist anymore well this was answered in
a story that dc wrote called the last
days of the jsa which basically killed
them all off and so post-crisis what
they did is they gave new origins to
effectively almost all the members of
the jsa that they didn't kill with the
exception of doctor fate instead what
they did is they wrote a four-issue
story that was actually written by jmd
matthias and keith given which basically
killed off the character of kent nelson
and then set naboo the mesopotamian god
on the path of trying to find a
replacement now over the course of the
next god like 30 years there were
several different versions of dr fate
which we're not going to go in depth
here you had eric strauss and then his
stepmom linda who were basically merged
into a singular person and they operated
as kind of a merger that became dr fate
eventually the eric strauss character
died and so linda took up the mantle of
dr fate by herself for a short period of
time there was a point where kent
nelson's dead wife was resurrected from
the dead and she became dr fate that
didn't last very long you had a guy
named jared stevens who played the role
of dr fate and then you had a guy named
kent v nelson who was actually the
nephew of the original kent nelson dr
fate but the reality here is that dr
fate as we know him played by kent
nelson didn't really resurface in any
meaningful and measurable way until dc's
relaunch slash reboot in 2011 with the
new 52. now the new 52 was not exactly
like the original christ on infinite
earth it wasn't exactly one of these
things where like it was a wholesale
reworking of the multiverse and all that
kind of stuff it was to a degree but it
was really more of a lot of the
superheroes in dc's lineup basically
getting new origin stories and dc
treating superheroes as if they'd only
existed for five years as opposed to
this great big huge sprawling history
now for dr fate himself his title didn't
actually come back until 2015 but even
then it wasn't really kent nelson the
way this worked out is that the mantle
of doctor fate is actually held by an
egyptian american grad student named
khalid nasseur and the way this is
played is that khalid is essentially
given the helm of fate by the egyptian
goddess bastet and at first is depicted
as being significantly weaker than past
versions of doctor fate however it's
later revealed that khalid's mother is
the niece of kent nelson and that kit
nelson himself would actually return and
serve as the mentor of khalid while the
two of them operated side by side both
of them sharing the mantle of doctor
faith now during dc's rebirth event and
dc rebirth was a very interesting
situation because when dc launched the
new 52 in a lot of ways it pissed off a
lot of comic book fans because a lot of
the history that they'd read before the
new 52 was just wiped away and so dc
rebirth was designed to bring back a lot
of that history that had been removed
and then merge it with the stories as
they'd been told following the new 52 so
if it seems a little wild and murky and
just kind of a huge mess it was it and
it still is it's still just a continuity
mess but with regards to the dc rebirth
event dr fate actually had a huge role
in justice league dark under the dc
rebirth banner now for those of you guys
who didn't hear of justice league dark
it was a really really cool line of
comics that they basically split the
justice league into several teams but
justice league dark essentially focused
on like the magic and mysticism side the
darker side but this comic line actually
saw naboo possess kent nelson's body and
then trapped khalid in a vase but after
he was freed by the justice league dark
he ended up playing a key role in
helping to defeat naboo and then free
kent nelson of his control resulting in
both kent and khalid agreeing to shelve
the dr fate mantle while serving as
magical advisors to the justice league
dark team now of course that didn't
really last very long and both khalid
and kent nelson would take up the mantle
once again largely because fans just
wanted to see them come back however
kent is killed in battle with a being
that's known as the upside down man when
he essentially sacrifices himself to
produce a spell powerful enough to
weaken the upside down man which was
enough for his teammates to ultimately
defeat him this leaves khalid as the
sole doctor fate in dc comics which is
actually where we are right now that
kent nelson is not the main doctor fate
which i know probably sounds
disappointing if you are interested in
the character from dc comics and you
want to go read about kent nelson you're
not going to see him right now at least
not as dr fate but that's kind of where
we are here at the moment that's one of
the big one of the big things to contend
with here dc's continuity is a nightmare
in so many different ways so trying to
take a character like dr fate who's been
around as long as he has and condense it
down into a digestible video can be a
bit of a chore but hopefully this video
served his purpose and hopefully you
walk away with a much better
understanding of dr fate
let me know down in the comment section
thank you all for watching and i will
catch you all later
peace